just feeling like the easy way
ultimately becomes the hard way
because you're not paying a price which
is
you know you you basically just make
mediocre work
so you know when you really when you
look at the story it's just about a guy
trying to get home
because there's a burglar in his house
you know he's like accompanied by his
annoying brother and a drunk chick and
this
bipolar guy is prone to temper tantrums
and
if you think about it like that just the
simplicity of the story
and this is my little here's my little
trick
i will write a draft and then i'll put
it away for a year
or so and then it would be two years
even three years and then i'll come back
to it and i'll read it
and i go who wrote this [ __ ] dude the
world needs
stupid [ __ ] we need the ridiculous
because who wants to go and say like who
wants to go and see a film
that reminds us about how terrible the
world is i think the world
needs we need an escape we need these
things to remind ourselves
that we are stupid creatures
[Music]
i find that taking
the risks is you reap
bigger rewards from that and if i feel
like i'm playing it safe or i'm too
complacent a bit too comfortable doing
something
then i feel like my work suffers and
it's happened a couple of times
just on sort of not even in film but
like in just in general life
just feel like the easy way ultimately
becomes the hard way
because you end up paying a price which
is
you know you you basically just make
mediocre work
so i find like kind of you know you kind
of force yourself to walk into the fire
a bit
and um and
and you're on your toes and you're you
know you're kind of just you're just
trying to survive constantly then you
come up with
really great new ideas and you know
you've come up with more inventive
solutions to the problems
the formula is make them more human
the thing with thor and i think with a
lot of the a lot of superheroes
at least is the weirdos you know they're
like
they're um it's very hard to relate to
them because
i had to get to figure out the um
the kind of human traits that they
possess especially with thor because
there's an alien
and you know and he's like a rich kid
lives in a palace and you know it's very
hard to kind of
understand where he's coming from um
so with with him the key really was to
um
was to tap into chris's strengths which
uh you know the fact that he's funny and
charming and
um and you know he's a kind of
friend who you would want to go on an
adventure with
yeah but also i think that they're very
relatable um
you know they have human characteristics
they have to they have to they have to
um you know
thor is um i mean essentially he's a
rich kid from outer space
you know he's uh he just wants to be
loved and you know he wants to be like
we're all rich kids who want to be loved
um and the hulk is uh you know it's
kind of like this bipolar disorder you
know can't control and
uh yeah i love the you know that the
theme of hulk
you know it's just an age-old idea of
wrestling these two
beings within you and i mean there is
really something if we look at every
character
they probably dress ridiculously but um
you know there's something related
is there is there similarities though i
mean it's i'm kind of painting like it's
two completely different worlds like
making more of an indie film they are
very similar like what
and the way that you get into these the
way that i i could kind of
you know make myself feel like i had
something to offer and and that
um i guess somehow that there was
an in for me creatively was to think of
this thing like an independent film
so you know when really when you look at
the story it's just about a guy trying
to get home
because there's a burglar in his house
and he's trying to get home you know
across
across the just happens to be across the
universities trying to he's trying to
travel
but um you know this is really like
after hours um
set in space you know he's like
accompanied by his annoying brother and
a drunk chick and this
bipolar guy is prone to temper tantrums
and
if you think about it like that just the
simplicity of the story
that's my in that's the way that i can
figure out how to make these characters
more
relatable to the audience and you know
humanize them
so i think failure is a brilliant thing
it teaches you a lot of stuff
and um and all you know and you you end
up coming up with better ideas often
when you
when you fail at things um and
you know i think what's really great
also is
learning to embrace
bad experiences bad creative experiences
and
you know watch bad movies you know read
bad books and
because all of that stuff sometimes it
teaches you what not to do and so
you know for me one bad experience i had
was i played a stripper on a tv show
once
um and you know i remember sitting
around in the green room in my g-string
thinking why am i doing this
just helping someone else to realize
their dream and so what i ended up doing
was i started writing my own
scripts and stuff in the screen in my
g-string and then
a few months later i made a short film
and then that went on to
go to the oscars about a year later
but i lost so obviously that was a
complete waste of time but um you know
it's it was me at the oscars asleep
when you go from having the first germ
of an idea for something
to writing your first draft do you
do you spend a lot of time sort of
really digging into and thinking you
really
really
know your characters inside out before
you start that first draft and do you
outline and do a treatment and know
every scene
or do you just kind of crack on with
your first draft and then rewrite
rewrite rewrite
yeah i i do the um
lots of notes and beats and like try and
figure out the story before typing
because i
find that typing is really horrible
um and just it just hurts um
your body and your mind just sit in
front of a
blank screen and now what's next i like
to just have the whole plan out in front
of me and know
and but basically how i rise i'll start
with the beginning and the end
just want to really like visually or
like just something that i think it's
like
this would be a cool way to end a movie
and there's a cool last image for an
audience to see
this would be a cool first image and
this will be a cool way to open the film
and then i'll start and then i'll put in
some scenes throughout i think this
would be a great film
scene and then eventually when i've got
enough of these scenes or sequences
then lazily just glue them all together
with some
sort of connecting scenes but that's it
really
that's sort of what i that's my style
and when i know what it is
then i can write really fast but if i'm
just sitting there with like
if you would say oh you wrote a story
about you know uh
soothsayer on a mission to find some
some herbs in fantasyland and then
i just had to look at a blank page i
would not i'd be there for a year
without typing anything unless i sat
down and like wrote out and figured it
all out before
so my one question is i also like like
writing scripts that aren't like the
huge
the usual script that's very like off
the beat and also like as a bit of humor
not
to the normal so how do you like what
advice would you give to pitch something
like that for two investors
and try and get them on board with
something that's not really of
the norm uh well
sadly i've never i mean i mean also i'm
happy about it but i've never had to
really do
pitching or try and like find finance
that way like
we're very lucky in new zealand with the
film commission like if you go to them
and you have a project that they believe
in then that's sort of how we get our
stuff funded
and so only outside of that i've only
worked with
marvel and um in recently fox
searchlight on my
uh world war ii film and but
traditionally what i do and i because
i've
a lot of friends who are writers and
they say things like oh
i've got this great ideas about this and
this is it oh great so you should write
that and they go
i'm going to wait till i get some
funding
i thought you you i thought you were a
writer
yeah yeah no no but i'm going to wait
until i'm going to put in my like
petition then
get some get some money and then i can
start writing but
that's not how it works you just if you
want to write something you're
passionate about it
just go write it like you just got to
write it
and so i've never traditionally i just
wrote my scripts until they were at a
point where
i thought that they were ready to shoot
and then i went for
finance i didn't go and then go i've got
a you know one page synopsis
and i want money so that i can start
like so my fingers will
work you know no i would just like
do the work write for a year and then go
in
and say this is what i've worked on i
think this film's good you know and
so that's how i work yeah i would do the
work first
and then take it to them first and
foremost don't don't
listen to people's advice and um
i'd say you really just like listen to
yourself and but you know it's
i i've i realized that
if you look at any artist you know it's
it's less about following them because
they probably didn't follow someone else
or they probably you know the great
artists didn't really copy
or try and um and replicate someone
else's career
and so i think that's that's an
incentive to really
stick to your own guns and follow your
own vision and do your own thing
i'd just say look at art is the the
thing that really
inspired me to to try different things
and i only came to screenwriting and
filmmaking
in my late twenties but before that
would have i would have come to london i
spent most of my time
at the galleries like the national and
the tate and stuff and i just
yeah i mean i i just love seeing
art in general it doesn't matter what it
is just having some sort of
um window into someone else's mind or
someone else's creative process
i think it all helps to inspire you and
to get you motivated to do your own
thing
but i actually that's the way i prefer
to write
and this is my little this is my little
trick
that none of you will want to do
i will write a draft and then i'll put
it away for a year
or so and then uh or even two years or
even three years and then i'll come back
to it and i'll read it
and i go who wrote this [ __ ] and then i
will read it like maybe two or three
times
and then i will throw that away
and then rewrite it from page one based
on the memory of
how of what i read and then my 120 page
script will suddenly be 80 pages
um and it'll just be the bare bones and
just like the
the yeah the important parts or the
members of the things that i've remember
from reading the script
and so i think there's that's like quite
a good filter system
and then when you have like this very
sort of bare bones short version of your
story
then you can add back in some tonal
stuff and some you know more
jokes and [ __ ] and stuff like that but
yeah so that takes a long
way longer than anyone wants to do how
many of those scripts do you have
in the drawer how many do you have or
well that's just i just put them in a
chat drive and then
put that somewhere i don't want to throw
it away
but i don't make sure i don't look at it
again
um so you're largely
you do mostly comedy that's like what
you're drawn to that's what you're doing
yeah you
voices i'm so sorry pigeon holds you
uh but my question is um did you always
know that was kind of the what you
wanted to write and do you have any
advice for people who want to write like
right now i'm writing something that's
like
very dramatic and tragic but
i'm i feel like oh stop just don't do it
we don't need any more depressing films
no when i wrote boy the first version of
boy was super depressing
and super sad and hunt for the world of
people the first version was like
just sad i was just like oh i'm going to
be like lucas medicine
i realized i don't know how to do that
i'm not good at that and so i just
i decided to just look at what i was
good at which is
you know you know i'm a reprobate and uh
you know i'm like i don't and i'm don't
like rules
and i don't like
depressing films like i just i decided i
made a choice i said to myself
do you really like depressing films and
i said back to myself in the husky voice
no no
and you know i then jermaine said a
really important thing to me when we
were doing when we were shooting
what we did in the shadows there was a
point where we were like
we're turning like a five minute idea
into a feature film this is what
we'll be doing and he goes dude the
world needs
stupid [ __ ]
we need we need the ridiculous
because you know
who wants to go and say like he wants to
go and see a film
that reminds us about how terrible the
world is
we just like go on twitter and uh you
know let's just look at the news
and save ourselves two hours you know so
it's
i think the world needs we need an
escape we need these things
to remind ourselves that we are stupid
creatures
we are clumsy we're the clumsiest of all
animals
you know nowhere in the animal kingdom
we see an animal that will like
smash their head like four times in a
row and like you know on something or
like you know
trip over themselves we are dumb as [ __ ]
so we should embrace that and so
yeah so yeah yes there's room for like
you know
beautiful um human films maybe the
dramatic but
i think that you can also
you know it's like a you know it's like
a little
um you subvert that you know it's like
it's like
it's like the payload is like the themes
and like you know the
stuff that means something but if the
plane is like
dressed like a clown and everyone's
going oh cool
and then you drop that payload like
that's the way i think
that makes a film important because
every day you think people walk around
being depressed all day long and i mean
some
some do yes but you know it's
no one walks around like you know in a
dancer in the dark kind of like
situation you know you know it's like
well
you know like breaking the waves like oh
this is a sad set
it's light and dark all day long you
know so i think that's what
why i like my films is because it's like
light and dark
and there's a mix and there's it's
you've got to find that balance but
that's
and that's why i think the way i try to
do things is
is more human
more in touch with like how humans are
every day
if you come from a [ __ ] background and
poor community
you laugh all day long you know
i developed my style of of
writing down all the beats and all of
the
the different parts of the the story
before actually
typing quite early on because i i
realized
i didn't really know i didn't know how
to format scripts back when i started
off and when i first started
screenwriting
it was like on microsoft word and
so i'd seen scripts from when i was an
actor but i didn't like
and so i don't use the space bar to go
all the way into the middle of the page
i didn't know about tab and it started
just using the spacebar to get all the
way there and then type the character's
name and then like press enter spacebar
all the way there to start doing the
dialogue so they're really wonky
and so so it took me a long time doing
that because
i i mean i didn't know how to do that
but also i didn't really know what i was
writing like i knew kind of what the
characters were doing but i got stuck
on black pages all the time so i started
just doing things by hand and writing
all my dialogue by hand
first so that's with all my short films
i'd write everything
by hand and then when i knew the
structure and i knew it when it was good
then i would
then i'd start typing it out i think it
all comes down to
putting the power back in into the in
the hands of
the people who own those stories and so
you know i think that
the only authentic way you can tell a
story from a particular place
is to get someone from that place you
know someone who knows that
content and knows the culture to tell it
yeah i
fully support the idea of getting
indigenous people to tell their stories
do you think i could borrow some money
i'm just a bit broke at the moment
well it's not fair man these kids get
more than we ever good oh i know it's
not a competition
never said it was a you grow up
i will spend more time with those boys
we're all the same and we all have the
same problems we all need to pay rent
and we all need to get a job and
feed our kids and so which is why you
know films like smoke signals was
you know such a great film when it came
out because it was like oh
they're just normal people so far
it's far [ __ ]
where's nowhere near you
i'd say it's a file those are the films
that i like and then so boy
really presented i think our culture as
as everyone else it's a very human story
but told in a very um
unique place the location was something
that not many people had seen before
so some of the responses were that you
know it was like it didn't
um spend enough time dwelling in like
the spirituality of maori and
how we you know how connected to the
like to the ghost world we are
or anything but which you know a lot of
us aren't
and so uh yeah i just tried to tell like
a normal story
about all people who happen to be brown
who are you
boy what boy hell hello
elemy
yeah oh hey
i'm your dad oh
hey dad hey welcome back good to see
you